and my next guest with the support of
the Majority Leader Mitch McConnell is
preparing investigations into the
political bias at the FBI that targeted
president Trump joining me now is the
head of the Senate Judiciary Committee
Lindsey Graham all right senator on the
theme of repercussions in both of these
cases can we expect the do J's full
involvement yeah I think so I think bill
Barr is a man of the Department of
Justice this has been his life's work
and I think he's very disappointed and
concerned by the way the FBI handled the
FISA warrant application the
counterintelligence investigation and
he's going to be very supportive of
looking to find out how this got off the
rails a lot of folks when they
approached me I'm traveling around the
country I'm sure you get the same thing
people say
how does Hillary's people how do they
manage to smash BlackBerry's how do they
unmask all of these Americans with
probably dubious for dubious reason how
was the UN Ambassador unmasking like
Samantha power like how is this all
happening there's never any
repercussions but what do you say to
them just on that score
well one let's find somebody to prove
that it did happen we all trust you know
Muller I stood behind him because I
thought he was a fair guy a lot of
people on our side thought he was in a
you know which are not dead and quite
frankly but the president's been
vindicated let's take somebody like
Muller to ask these questions did they
get an advisor warrant by using
compromised bogus information yeah I
think so but let's somebody other than
Lindsey Graham and Laura Ingraham said
let's find somebody of the stature of a
Muller to look at the other side of the
story because if they find something I
want people to believe this based on the
evidence not politics is Bill Barr now
looking into the possibility of
appointing and other special accounts I
am urging him for one simple reason this
is an emotional event most Republicans
believe they're out to get Trump most
people think that struck in page--and
McCabe and Comey wanted Clinton to win
and Trump to lose and they took the law
in their own hands if that's true is
horrible let's find somebody that can
tell us if it's true take the
appropriate action I think it's very
important to have a Muller light figure
oh you think that but you've had
conversations with borrow your dinner
with them the
Knight is he approaching that decision
is there a timetable and with us to make
that decision I think I think he's gonna
look at what happened and the question
for him should it be me and the
professionals here inside the building
or should I get somebody outside the
system it's not a question of if he
looks is how he looks well they're
attacking him now they're trashing his
credibility on the left they're saying
that he's just a political actor that
Muller shouldn't have trusted him to
make that obstruction decision I've
never heard of someone who is a Bush
Attorney General everyone's you know
elevating the bushes now for a variety
of reasons but I've never heard anyone
attacked bill bar in his professionalism
until the left got into there multiple
stages of grief here well so like Adam
Schiff has become the new Oliver Stone
of the house there's nothing will ever
satisfy them bill Barr is one of the
greatest people to ever serve in the
Department of Justice highly respected
on both sides of the aisle until Trump
got to be President the point I'm making
is let's have somebody that that maybe
we can find like a Muller to look at the
other side now let's talk about a man
who you probably wouldn't recommend take
over this investigation Jim Comey he was
not gonna be seen tonight he was last
seen gazing up at the redwoods
a lineup to me Lindsay anyway so he was
on NBC tonight commenting let's watch if
there are questions that haven't been
answered in the a force and hours and
hours of testimony
I've given of course I'll answer them I
want it all done in the light of day
though no more secret depositions public
hearings to serve the public interest so
if they're questions to be asked about
how we handle this investigation or any
other let me know when you want me he's
ready okay so one it's gonna be in
public and I'm gonna give you a heads-up
but one of the questions if I'm Ashley
did Bruce or tell you you shouldn't
trust Christopher still and how much
time and attention did you put into
verifying the dossier before you
certified to the court that it was
reliable so there you go think about it
come to the committee here soon and
you'll give me the answer in public you
will testify my friend in public not
behind closed doors and you will answer
for your
timeis FBI director now I want to get
your taking another event that happened
to one of your former colleagues Senator
Joe Biden now he seems poised to launch
a presidential bid right but like a lot
of the Democratic candidates he has to
say he's sorry about a lot of what he
did now here he's attempting to
apologize for how a Nita Hill my old my
old boss Clarence Thomas confirmation
hearings let's watch there are a bunch
of white guys she faced a committee that
didn't fully understand what the hell is
all about to this day I regret I
couldn't come up with a way to get her
the kind of hearing she deserved he's a
good guy if he's not proud of life he's
lived why should we make him president I
mean if you really have to apologize for
most of the things you've done in your
political life why should we pick you
for being president I think it's I think
his comment is actually racially charged
me and when I say that I think by saying
if it's a panel of white men you can't
be fair here's judge that is judging
someone based on race the price thought
we weren't supposed to do that the
problem of is that the part of Joe Biden
is dead and he's trying to find a way in
the new party you know the new party you
have to apologize because of you're a
white guy you can't possibly be fair
this is what's going to undercut him
because I like Joe Barton I like the the
real Joe Biden I think he's been wrong
on policy but what he's doing now is
putting in question whether or not he's
authentic do you really believe he
thinks that this apology is sincere is
he just trying to position himself for
political advantage I think he's
apologizing to get an advantage in a
crazy primary Lindsey Graham it is so
great to see you don't be a stranger
thanks